when I was 38 I accepted an assignment
in Mongolia and I'd been writing stories
for The New Yorker and before that New
York magazine for 20 years and this was
going to be the last adventure like this
for a while because I was about to start
on another kind of adventure I was 5
months pregnant and I was about to have
a new kind of life and I wasn't worried
about it my doctor had said it was fine
to fly until the third trimester and I
just you know I was not concerned but
the second night I was in Mongolia I
went to Y went into labor in my hotel
room and I gave birth and for ten
minutes
I was somebody's mother and when I got
home from Mongolia I was so sad I could
barely breathe and you know friends or
women who knew what had happened to me
would take one look at me and literally
burst into tears and I actually
understand how that felt for them now
because now women come to my readings
and things and I see them and I look at
them and I immediately know what they're
gonna tell me they have a particular
kind of look they just look blown apart
and I think it's something the reason I
wrote about it in this essay for The New
Yorker called Thanksgiving in Mongolia
was that I felt like why doesn't anybody
talk about this this is incredibly
intense experience that a lot of women
have and when it happens to you there's
no literature about very little so you
feel insane you feel like a crazy person
that you're having that level of grief
for a baby who wasn't even quite a baby
and are you the only person who's having
this reaction to this experience but the
answer's no I mean I at this reading I
gave from my book the rules do not apply
last week in San Francisco lady raised
her hand and she was like you know I
have three children who are alive I lost
four babies I'm 77 years old and I miss
every one of them and that was amazing
to me I mean I mean more and more
meaning women who are older who are like
oh yeah you know I've I've it's never
stopped hurting I mean it goes away at
your first you sort of live in grief
like in a tunnel of grief and then
eventually grief lives in you and it's
just something you take with you and
you're not walking around about to cry
but it is a big thing and I and I think
that in more general terms things that
have to do with this business with this
animal experience of being a woman you
know not every woman is going to have a
child not every woman is going to lose a
child God knows but every woman at some
point in her life is gonna have some
kind of intense experience around
menstruation fertility childbirth child
loss menopause all this stuff all this
animal stuff about being a woman we
don't talk about and it's an enormous
part of the lives of half the human
population we should talk about it I
think so when I got back from Mongolia I
wrote this essay about the experience of
losing my baby there and the reason I
did that well there was no reason it
just happened it sort of came out of my
fingers and I didn't think about it but
if I were to think about it subsequently
you know part of the reason I did it was
because just like anyone else is proud
of their offspring I was proud of mine I
mean I think if you have children who
are alive most people I know who have
kids spend a certain amount of time
looking at them and being like oh my god
I made you you're a person like look at
you you're beautiful and I did that you
know for only for ten minutes but I did
do it and I was proud I was like world
I made a person no one knows but me no
one met him alive but me I'm gonna write
about this because I feel compelled to I
want for some you know for whatever it's
worth I want to procreate proclaim this
person's life happy
and that was why I wrote it now why I
published it was that I thought it was a
matter of feminism that that should be a
legitimate subject for writing for
literature for publication and the
response I got to that made me realize I
should write about it more
[Music]
you